where we go from one New York set new
york times bestseller to another one
stephen dubner with it he is the one of
two authors of freakonomics how did this
get to be on some bestseller list for
over a year I thought you're gonna ask
how it got to be published in the first
place it's a bit of a mystery to us
frankly I mean it's a book that's
nominally about economics to some degree
although it's meant to be a fun and
enlightening book and and it's also a
book that doesn't really have a theme
it's not about you know any particular
global crisis it's not about any
particular problem that we're trying to
solve it's really using the tools of
economics which are these wonderful
tools that are really great at answering
questions about human behavior and yet
are usually the tools of economics are
usually applied to subjects that are
very important but less interesting too
many of us than human behavior so the
economy and inflation in the stock
market so what we do I co-authored the
book with Steve Levitt who's a wonderful
and very creative economist at the
University of Chicago and he's done a
lot of research and together we decided
to tell stories using economics to
explore the kind of subjects that we
want to read and write about so about
parenting about cheating corruption
crime whether the name you give your
child has any effect on on their outcome
and again using these tools that are
very powerful and intuitive in a way to
get it answers that a lot of people
ended up wanting to know about well we
wanted to have you here while we're here
at be EA so that we could let our
viewers talk to you so we're going to
give put the numbers up right away
here's how you do it 2025 853 885 for
Democrats 3886 for Republicans and 20 25
853 887 for others can I ask you a naive
question i was watching in my hotel
before I came out why the different
numbers for dems Republicans and others
just so we get a lot of different
thoughts and opinions but why need why
different number why different phone
numbers that's right oh well you have to
the way you have to go there and these
have sure that we take 1 111 was we
would never know I was just curious as
to
very good good to know the method I know
there's some method Salters interesting
to me okay yeah why don't you think one
isn't a toll number and the other is
free and right now they're all they're
all they're all the same here I'll talk
you talked so much about the about the
fact that every so much of what we know
in conventional wisdom is wrong what
kind of examples do you give well their
various I mean I'll give a very simple
example in the book we asked a question
which is more dangerous if you're a
parent with young children which is more
dangerous a gun or a swimming pool in
other words if you have a choice about
sending your child to play at a friend's
house and that friend has the friend's
parents have guns in the house or a gun
and another friend who has a swimming
pool in the backyard I think most
parents would typically think oh gosh
watch the gun okay as it turns out many
more children young children die each
year in backyard swimming pool accidents
than die by gunfire okay so then you
begin to ask well Plus which there are
probably 200 million guns in this
country and many many many many fewer
swimming pools in that so the incidence
is much higher so you have to ask
yourself how do various conventional
wisdoms get formed and they get formed
by people like you and me I write for
The New York Times Magazine and the
media we try our very best to give
across information that is as true and
accurate and kind of holistic true in
the big sense as we can and yet a lot of
conventional wisdom is formed because
various experts will whisper into your
ear or my ear and tell us a story that
is true on one level but it's very hard
for journalism to present the entire
truth globally and so what we try to do
is forget about how you feel about an
issue and and an issue I would include
whether it's politics or religion or
crime or a swimming pool versus a gun
forget about how you feel about it and
forget about what your emotions or
opinions are particularly anecdotes site
and look at the numbers and that's what
we do is we just walk up to an issue
forget about what you think you know
look at the data analyze the data as
rigorously and as kind of truthfully as
you can and then tell the story is based
on that how do you know the data is
correct well that's where it's great for
me as a journalist to be working with a
world-class economist
I mean an economist most people don't
realize this what economists do I would
argue probably better than anyone in the
world is work with data they are
empirical researchers in other words
they will work very hard to get a hold
of a data set or sometimes create a data
set and then measure it and that's where
the tools of economics are really
valuable in this statistically they're
sophisticated I mean a lot of people
don't like economics because it's become
overly mathematical in these last 50 or
80 years that's true and I don't like
that either the good news is that the
math is very useful in figuring out what
the data really have to say and the
better news is that economics long ago
when it was founded by Adam Smith back
in Scotland centuries ago Smith was a
moral philosopher he was not trying to
figure out pricing strategy or where a
stock market was going he was trying to
figure out how when changes happen in
the world through industrialization in
that case how is human behavior
effective and that's what we try to do
is we try to use data to look at human
behavior and to kind of measure the
difference between what people think or
what they say they're going to do in a
case and what they actually do here's a
piece of data I bet you know how many
books have you sold oh we're about a
million and a half in this country and
how does that compare with what AG
normal non-fiction book might do oh gosh
I don't know what normal is but it is
it's a lot I mean it's it's it's absurd
it's absurd on one level I mean there's
also in sociology there's a thing called
the Matthew effect which comes from the
New Testament Matthew the idea being
that the rich get rich and the poor get
poorer the rich get richer the poor get
poorer and what you see with a
best-seller and you see this in our
culture in general it is kind of a
blockbuster culture people gravitate to
the things that are doing well and then
they push them more and make them do
even better it's not fair it so it's
lucky is what it is honestly so I've
never been the beneficiary of this big
of a piece of luck I enjoy it but it
also it's a little bit odd frankly to
witness it first call for you is from
Fresno California hello good afternoon
as good afternoon I'm trying to
compliment this year's book and
economics they enjoyed it very much and
also love c-span and your coverage I had
a kind of a two-prong question how I'm
wondering mr. Debra how you and your
co-authors arrived in the chapter
regarding Stetson Kennedy and the Ku
Klux Klan and including that and then if
you can if you can touch on the recent
controversy in Europe editorial in the
New York Times about new information
that led you to believe that he didn't
infiltrate the clan and I know that
that's sort of a two-pronged question
but I appreciate it I'll hang up and
listen to the answer saying sure thank
you okay so that's a great question it's
um it's a little bit of a complicated
story so I'll try to tell it as briefly
and it's kind of succinctly as I can we
have a chapter in the book called what
do a group of real estate agents have in
common with the Ku Klux Klan and the
answer is that both of them real estate
agents and the Klan back in the day
especially dealt with what economist
called information asymmetry an insight
was pretty language but this is the
language that we use and what an
information asymmetry is is very
basically it's when there are two
parties in a transaction or more than
two and one usually a seller has a lot
more information about what's being sold
than the buyer there's an unbalanced
information situation there and in the
case of real estate agents we write
about that how real estate agents have
an information advantage that they'll
often exploit to their good and the Ku
Klux Klan we wrote a story about this
amazing infiltration of the clan back in
the 1940s by man named Stetson Kennedy
who went undercover supposedly joined
the Ku Klux Klan and got all this
information this was a years-long effort
on his behalf he was a civil rights
activist long ago he gathered all this
information about the Klan and then used
that information that he gleans secretly
and disseminated it over the airwaves
this was in the heyday of radio so he
would give information to the Superman
radio hour and to Drew Pearson a big
political commentator of the day and
they disseminated the infamous
about the clan and when the secret
information became public it did two
things it made it much less powerful and
it made it it made the clan kind of
infantilize because they were this
secret society so we wrote about this
story in our book we had interviewed
Stetson Kennedy who's now I think 89
years old lives in Florida he'd written
a number of books many articles over the
years and been lauded is really a hero
for among many other things having
infiltrated the plan after our book was
published it came to our attention that
there were archives around the country
that had information about Stetson
Kennedy's work which which implied that
he had not personally done as much of
the infiltration as he had represented
in his own book and as he had told us in
interviews and as we therefore it
written about in freakonomics so we
wrote an article in the new york times
magazine where we have a regular
freakonomics column and we wrote about
the fact that we had been misled or
misinformed and particularly the Stetson
Kennedy according to all the documents
that we were then able to gather after
the book had exaggerated his role in
personally gathering this information
infiltrating the plan so in order to
correct the record and try to give his
complete record of that history as
possible what we did is we wrote that
New York Times column we put a lot of
the information on our website for
economics com and now we're revising the
chapter in freakonomics we're publishing
in the fall and expanded and revised
edition with new material and some
revisions and the major revision will be
the Stetson Kennedy chapter the revision
hardback paper bed it's it's still in
hardback I mean this is a publishing
decision it's still a best-seller in
hardback and so they're choosing to keep
it in in hardback for a while I mean the
good news for buyers is it with
discounting at a lot of a lot of places
hardbacks these days are oddly enough
not that much more expensive than trade
paperbacks used to be which i think is
one reason why you see a lot more
hardcovers stay in print as hardcovers
longer Charlotte North Carolina go ahead
oh yes mr. doubler yes how are you I
heard your first question about the
numbers I always had that question also
I still didn't quite get an answer to
these two the question I'm still can
fused about those three different
numbers but the rain reason I called is
because it ties in to the previous
person who but the pleasant lady was
interviewing I'm sorry I don't remember
your name of han lin Connie yes I was
wondering in your opinion from your
writing your book in this and the
research you had to have done how is
white Americans a viewpoint those with
power how does that influence their
viewpoint of black Americans in terms of
the pigmentation of the black American
and the philosophy or the philosophy
that the Black American may have in
terms of their view on economics in
general and in terms of of whether or
not the door to economic power is open
to them thanks I'll hang up I'll hang up
into your answer okay thank you that's a
fantastic question and a really hard
questions let me answer the the first
easier question first briefly from what
I understand from what Connie told me if
you have three separate numbers and you
are c-span and you're picking from Group
A then group B then Group C you're going
to have a steady rotation of different
political affiliations which I think
this pretty great idea as long as people
don't try to game the system i mean we
write actually a lot in the book about
Shane this is right so if you want to
game the system and if you're a Democrat
you want to get in more often or you
want to present a different viewpoint
you can just call the Republican line
but we try to catch it may it be very
interesting for us to actually look at
the numbers there and see what kind of
cheating what kind of level cheating r
is because that's what we try to do is
use the tools of economics and data to
see in what ways are people being honest
and charitable and on the other hand you
know dishonest and cheating and stealing
an answer to your second question we
don't really write a lot about what most
people think of as the economy or
especially macroeconomics in terms of
the gap between black and white
achievement and education and income in
this country was a huge and hugely
important question which we kind of
around the edges at in our book but i
will tell you there's a fellow who we do
write about in freakonomics his name is
Roland fryer fr ye are and he's a young
economist at Harvard he's 28 years old a
young african-american economist and we
write about him a little bit in this
book I'm actually working on a book
about him that'll take probably a few
years what's remarkable about Roland
fryer is his background was a very
difficult one in which it really
encompasses a lot of what we think of as
a modern African American experience
meaning a lot of very good things a lot
of very difficult things from a familial
perspective to a educational perspective
what Roland is doing at Harvard now is
he is turning his attention very much
like the book the Covenant with black
America is attempting to do he's turning
his attention to what he calls the the
situation of black underachievement in
this country in other words he's looking
very precisely at the numbers in the
ways in which african-americans are
lagging behind whites and some other
groups in education and health outcomes
and income outcomes and a variety of
things because he's an economist he's
not approaching this with a political
agenda and frankly because he is black
himself he's able to deal with issues
that others might not be able to so he
has been studying a lot of things having
to do with the acting white phenomenon
for instance where black children are
often thought to be held back or hold
themselves back because they don't want
to be subject to ridicule by their black
peers for achieving too well in school a
phenomenon that would be seen as acting
white instead of just theorizing about
it or a pining about it he uses data and
he tries to look at the effect of that
how it happens and if so what can be
done to ameliorate it so the best answer
I have to your very good and very
difficult question frankly is keep an
eye on Roland fryer jr. and there are
others like him who again I think we're
getting to a point in history which i
think is encouraging that people are
using data to look at these very
difficult problems and when you use data
and your allegiant to what the data have
to say then your politics and your
opinion and your emotions are often
removed
and I find that it's often the most
fruitful way to solve a problem we're at
Book Expo America it's taking place to
share in Washington DC and we are
talking with Stephen Dubner who is one
of the authors of freakonomics as we
take our next call will show you a
little bit of what the the floor of the
expo looks like as booksellers and
librarians across the country are
looking at the possibilities of buying
some fall books from publishers Niagara
Falls you're next hello oh I'm going to
be on the line by the way I did obey the
rules I did call the Republican line so
I am left leaning on most issues so
there you go my question actually is a
good follow-up to the last question it
was regarding naming children and naming
conventions I work in an inner city
charter school in buffalo new york and
many of the names of the children that I
teach are made up by the mother they are
some of them are pretty you what you'd
expect shaquan and chiquilla but some of
them really flouse these Hooked on
Phonics I guess conventions with the
different Ariana's Ariana's spelled r e
ona ar e Anna and so I was wondering
about the earning potential of children
whose names are made up that really kind
of flout the pronunciation conventions
obviously that has to have some effect
as opposed to the other you would think
so when you uh we actually have a
chapter an entire chapter in the book
which probably a lot of people to argue
is way too much on on baby names on the
on what a name actually what kind of
significance the name actually has what
a name is meant to be so let me take a
step back from it before I answer your
question particularly if you think about
what a name is it's an odd thing really
you know I'm a parent so I and my wife
when we have a child we decide on the
name we're going to give the kid and
that kid is I'm going to go through his
or her entire life with this name that
we gave it before we knew anything about
this kid it's kind of odd if you think
about it in other words it would sort of
make more sense if people got to pick
their own names at a certain point in
their life so i'm not i'm not very
politically involved if i were i might
argue for national naming age you know
at age 14 or 16 or 18 everybody gets the
look at their name brittany anas I don't
want to be Brittany I want to be
Cassandra what I right I don't think
there's a lot of you know a lot of
upside and me pushing that movement
that's kind of the thinking so what what
is the name a name is really in economic
terms it's a parent's it's the parents
signaling device they are signaling to
the world and when I say the world I
mean to their friends their community
their co-workers their family whatever
what they expected this child do they
expect it to be a traditional child they
expect it to be a successful child and
they six expect it to stay within the
very tight culture they may live in or
out in the world or so on and so what we
look at is what kind of effect a name
will actually have on a child and there
have been studies over the years that
show that suggested that if you have a
distinctly let's say African American
name in the United States or a
distinctively immigrant sounding name in
Britain let's say that that name itself
is a huge handicap dear life outcome and
this research was suggested by some
things called audit studies where you
send out identical resumes with two
different names you know Jane Smith and
shakeela Smith okay my co-author on
freakonomics Steve Levitt along with
Roland fryer The Economist's I mentioned
a moment ago did a lot of work using a
big big big pile of data names database
from California including I think 40
million names and they found that if you
actually track the life outcome of
people who have a distinctly
african-american name versus an
equivalent person meaning someone from
the same kind of background same kind of
parents with a mainstream American white
sounding name there's no difference in
the life outcome in other words it's not
the name that has an effect on your life
now that's not to say that someone named
shakeela won't have a worse outcome in
life than someone named Jane you know
what she will but that's because someone
with the name of shakeela is more likely
to have been named by someone with a low
income low education set of parents in
other words it's an indicator of what
kind of house will they come from but it
doesn't
it doesn't actually cause anything in
that a lot of what we argue in
freakonomics is to try to distinguish
between indicators and causes or more
better put between correlation and cause
a lot of times two things move together
and people assume that one causes the
other whereas in fact they don't Ohio's
next Painesville Ohio you're on Stephen
doesn't it yeah I read the book I
thought it was pretty good and I kind of
had the same thought myself I remember
when the 55 mile an hour speed limits I
came in the idea was to save gas and
when they wanted to bring it back it
would save lives so it was something
different which is why I figured maybe
the AIDS crisis might be great cheer for
poverty everybody would why the eighth
grade kid private money for poverty and
okay huh I'm sorry was I missed the
question I'm sorry no I didn't go
everybody would be scared of getting
aids that all tried to save shouts and
use condoms and they wouldn't have all
these illegitimate children and I would
help to make things better that didn't
happen partially because I gay men were
the ones wearing titles but why do you
think that didn't happen and I have
there been many unforeseen side effects
of AIDS you know that's a good question
I think there is research on the kind of
overarching societal effects of AIDS and
I'm just not familiar with it enough to
speak about the one piece of the
research i do know that we did write
about in our New York Times column was
actually a really interesting question
it asked whether AIDS had an effect on
sexual preference in other words and
what the data say is that it did in
other words what happened is there were
gay men during the the height of the
AIDS crisis or aids scare however you
want to look at it hooba can't who began
having less sex with men and more sex
with women
there were heterosexual women who began
having less sex with men and more sex
with women in other words there's data
to suggest that what aids did the fear
of AIDS did is it made men on the
marginally it's not in great mass but on
the margin made men less likely to be
homosexual and women more likely to be
homosexual all right well it's also
really interesting about this research
this was done by a graduate student at
the university of chicago named andrew
francis it showed that not only did he
looked at people who had a relative or
yeah it was a family member who died of
AIDS and among those people he saw that
gay people who had a family member who
died of AIDS now did they switch their
sexual behavior often but in surveys
they would switch their sexual
declarations about themselves their
sexual identity in other words they
would be more likely to answer that
they're not attracted to members of the
same sex and so on so this was our very
narrow effort to try to address a
question that's on the mind of a lot of
people which is what is homeless what is
sexuality in general is it an innate
preference or is it a learnin
environmental choice and it's a really
interesting a problem to try to address
or an issue to try to address and again
economics would seem to be an unlikely
set of tools to use it but it kind of
worked last call for our guests
Edgewater New Jersey hi hello mr.
governor i enjoy your writing very much
thank you I'd like to ask you uh it
seems it tell me it correct me if I'm
wrong but as far as I know roughly five
four at least in America five percent of
the country has ninety percent of the
wealth or controls ninety percent of the
wealth I think it's somewhere in that
neighborhood again correct me if I'm
wrong I don't know the number but we'll
proceed as if that's so all right the
question I'd like to ask has any
economists that you know ever has anyone
done the study let's say let's say just
for the sake of argument roughly
everybody was paid the same maybe three
tiers you know doctors would maybe get
eighty thousand regular people would get
sixty thousand and maybe down to forty
thousand that was below end it could is
if that wealth was spread out what I'm
asking is what kind of middle-class life
could everybody live as opposed to
people being terrified that the
going to lose their health care and and
having all these living in this land of
many malls yeah I grew up loving America
I hate America now aside from the big
cities it's all it's all the same burger
kings and the same stores and every
place in the country looks exactly the
same it's it's horrible well let me
begin by saying since I'm not an
economist I'm not going to wax
econometric alee about macroeconomics
what I will say is this what economists
generally feel is that markets work and
the reason markets work is because we
people are self-interested okay so Adam
Smith hundreds of years ago made a very
powerful argument he said when left to
their own devices people will compete
for goods and services so what we write
about in freakonomics is really we talk
about economics is really the study of
incentives which is to say the study of
how people get what they want or need
especially when other people want or
need the same thing now that may not
sound a lot like what we think of as the
economy but I would argue that it
actually is what Adam Smith declared was
that you know when people are
self-interested when they compete
markets are very efficient and there is
what he called an invisible hand that
seems to shape society in a way that as
it turns out is pretty benign is often
you know when when there is a need for
help in some quarter if left to its own
devices a free market will essentially
create that help and when people are
competing for goods and services a lot
of good things happen that's the
argument again that most economies would
make a lot of other people would make
exactly the argument or the plea that
you're making which is I hate this
disparity it seems unfair it seems cruel
it seems wrong it seems unamerican what
we do know if we were having this
conversation 50 years ago I it might be
a harder answer right now I think we can
have an answer to your question how do
planned economies work the answer is not
very well the Soviet Union had a very
very well planned economy top to bottom
I never spent a lot of time the Soviet
Union I I know and have worked with a
lot of people who have my wife is one of
them
and what you see is when the market does
not exist for people to compete for
things that they want when a central
planned economy is responsible for
dictating the quality of life of
everyone you have a great deal more
corruption you have less equity you have
less a gala Terry and approaches to life
style to outcomes and so on and so what
I would argue is it's a little bit like
what you say when you're in a place with
stormy weather if you don't like the
shape of this country with the burger
kings or the malls whatever it is stick
around ten years and it's going to
change markets move fast markets move
efficiently and so I I know that's not a
very satisfying answer but I think that
we often attribute evils to planning or
things that don't exist and really I
would argue that this economy in this
country politically and the capitalism
are actually producing an awful lot of
good for an awful lot of people and for
those who aren't doing as well yet the
opportunity exists Stephen Dubner people
buy now or wait for the fall your book
it's up to them their preference this is
what it looks like freakonomics a rogue
economist explores the hidden side of
everything mr. Devon wrote this along
with a Steven Levitt thanks very much
thank you very much today and book TV is
here we are have been live all day at
Book Expo which is the annual book trade
show it's the largest book trade show in
the country and we have this year it's
in washington DC at the washington
convention center well besides the floor
and the kinds of things that we've been
showing you today there are many panel
discussions and speeches that happen
throughout the four days and three or
four days a book expo the kickoff speech
for this year was tim russert and tim
russert was talking about his brand new
book wisdom of our fathers lessons and
letters from daughters and sons wex were
going to show you in its entirety mr.
Ezard speech from thursday night